thank you
[Music]
all right have you guys heard about
Miranda Sings AKA Colleen Ballinger
this is kind of a weird topic for me
because I know these people so this is
gonna be a little weird feel the [__]
Bean Steve okay so uh this is one of
those crazy things right so you when you
know somebody you don't necessarily know
everything about them obviously that's
what everyone says about serial killers
and like everyone who's a neighbor like
OJ Simpson's neighbors like he was the
nicest [__] guy in the universe you
know what I mean but I mean like how
would they know they just probably just
went like this like three times and all
of a sudden they're the nicest guy in
the neighborhood exactly you don't know
anybody don't [__] know so when I
knew Colleen Ballinger she was doing the
Miranda Sings character and
um where did you meet her I'm like I met
her in 2013 I think or 20 I think I'm
better in 2011.
um just in the tuber space like everyone
sees everyone at the same places and
[__] I need more context Beyond just
meeting her how close did you get with
them
uh I was very close with her husband
and then I knew her and her husband and
we hung out a bunch and um so outside of
work you guys hung out yeah yeah quite a
bit you guys been into each other's
houses is she still with her husband no
no that's part of all this stuff oh okay
it's a whole thing so you guys were
friends like
Beyond work yeah and I met her husband
her husband used to work at one of the
big mcns yeah and he was just a normal
dude and then he became stupefied like
with her and then as she grew like they
both started to kind of change and it
was like very strange too he was off
camera working out at MCM yes and then
so he became on camera yes and then he
started changing he's acknowledged this
he's very um
um emotionally intelligent he's like is
aware of like what he went through yeah
yeah but this story is kind of crazy
because so right now she's being accused
of grooming kids okay which is a crazy
accusation and allegation to him she was
like the Mr Rogers of like YouTube what
was her console version her content was
like doing a a theater uh kid like
parody basically named Miranda and she's
like this person who like
seems like she has some kind of
disability or something and she's
um you know talks funny and she is very
literal about things and it's very like
she's you can tell she's trying to do a
character right so she's trying to like
make fun of someone that she knew or a
group of people that she knew and
satirized like a topic wait with the
lipstick lipstick all of her lipstick
was all over the place all over the
place and her hair's all crazy yeah and
she's like I'm hot and like uh boys love
me I've seen her I've seen her before
yes but I think her audience was a lot
of girls right a lot of young girls 10
year old whatever and when she was
coming up she started off doing like
these parody songs but like it was
purposefully bad but then people were
not quite sure if it was actually bad or
not because she was playing the
character a little more like like it's
like she turned into Pee-wee Herman
later but she was playing a little more
straight initially and so people were
genuinely confused online it's just a
real person Landing in the gray Zone
exactly and then like later on as it
like grew and grew and grew she turned
it more into more of a literal character
where she was like more outlandish and
[__] but apparently so as she's amassing
this audience right and I saw this
happen like she had like no subscribers
when I met her
when she was coming up and then she like
starts exploding on the scene and then
um
apparently during like during all this
in the behind the scenes she has a group
of kids in a group called The weenies
which is like a private chat I'm like on
like one of the you know um messaging
apps and those are like a bunch of
little kids basically like at the time
like 14 13 12 like all ages of but not
above 18. it seems and and in those
chats she's saying like inappropriate
things to them like ask them about their
favorite sexual positions like one of
the kids in there she sent underwear to
like like in the mail in the mail I hope
it was new and when it was new and
that's the thing when I say that
immediately elicits a response from all
of us very natural response the context
is a little bit different because she
was like they had just gone to like a
store bought a bunch of [__] they
thought it was funny they bought
underwear and they thought in the video
they thought it'd be funny to send this
person underwear right and you know sexy
underwear whatever that's [__] weird
right yeah right but yeah sexy underwear
yeah oh it's sexy underwear sexy
underwear yeah I think it's just funny
if it was like Ninja Turtle underwear or
something
not bad wish you were around back then
yeah it could have been a little angel
on the shoulder could have helped it
would have been great so she um
she also
um gave so there's a kid named Adam
McIntyre who's come out about this
situation he was in that weenies group
that I'm talking about and apparently
like as she
like you know
she was with her husband and the big
thing about her and her husband was that
she would talk [__] on her husband like
constantly to the kids to everybody well
was that a joke or was that real it was
real it was a real [__] I was just
venting about venting about her husband
like being embarrassing she's humiliated
by him at all times like just talking
the most [__] I've ever heard of human
being talked then why is she with him
dude it was weird it was like one of
those things really kind of
uncomfortably laughing you're like damn
this [__] we're not [__] around
she's like really really like staying
this fellow so when you guys would hang
out would she like kind of talk [__]
openly to like she would she would be
like um passive aggressive with him but
then when he leaves the room she's
launching whoa
and by that point because I had known
him for a while by that point it was
just really weird because you're closer
to him than he's closer to him than her
and I was like I don't want to like get
in the middle of [__] or whatever and
then me and him kind of had a falling
out because like he did a show
um he just I don't know dude he started
to change it he's acknowledged all this
too I'm not really talking [__] on him
per se at the time this is what happened
changed a lot like he got a real big
head about stuff and
he would like do like um he would like
sing on stage and stuff like that
and I remember one time
um yeah he just was like dude you are
you're just very fake now I don't really
um you know I don't really but I was
more passive aggressive about it I was
kind of like satirizing him a lot yeah
like on my Instagram and stuff and like
satirizing like the types of people who
like face tune their images and [__]
like he was one of the people many
people were doing it but he took it very
personally that I was doing that at all
and so we kind of had a falling out and
then we see each other like two years
later at one of the cons right and then
um I was just like hey dude like uh you
know he just like sees me I see him we
have an awkward Exchange in the hallway
and then um he's like hey dude I'm gonna
go to the bar later if you would like to
talk and I was like yeah dude that
because I was like we need to talk and
then we sit down and I was like dude if
you and me are gonna be cool I can't
just pretend like
um I can't like just sit here and just
not say anything it's like yeah your
wife talks the most [__] on you like
have anybody I've ever heard
whoa damn yeah and and by that point I
knew it was okay to say that because he
was talking about how things weren't
great with him and her yeah and so I was
just kind of like giving a little bit of
that like it's okay champ like you're
probably gonna mentioned you're on the
right Road here like I think this is
probably a good move whereas if I did
that years prior it would've been
awkward and you probably would have like
been an inappropriate move I think that
would have made you guys not cool over
that yeah and I don't want to do that
anyway but for this because it's kind of
like I had a friend who was like
cheating on his wife and like I just
refuse I just like said I'm never gonna
talk to them again okay later because I
found out he was actually doing that so
I'm not gonna step in the middle and be
like he's cheating on you okay see you
later you know like why would I do that
but in this case he was already feeling
this like tug and I was like yeah dude
you're right just so you know you're
right yeah right and then we were cool
after that and then like um
you know it's kind of weird seeing like
this kid Adam McIntyre talked about how
you know he used to work for Colleen and
like she would message him all the time
and she would talk [__] all over Josh
and this boy was like 14 at the time he
was like 14 years old talking [__] about
him in the weenies Group which just
makes so much sense because like I would
like every time all my tuber friends
were around her and he left the room
she's like [__] clowning on this guy
it was like wild it was like so mean too
it was like man you really just hate
this this is your husband you [__]
hate this guy so then um this guy Adam
McIntyre came out I think he's very well
spoken young man
um and he came out a couple years ago
um because Colleen ended up tweeting
something from the Miranda Sings account
that was about like uh lgp LGBT like
coming out and she was like hey I'm
coming out and then it was a joke at the
end it wasn't like anything serious
joking about coming out she was talking
about coming out but it was like I'm
coming out like uh that I like to eat
donuts or whatever
I think it was a fart joke or something
like that it was it was a
tongue-in-cheek thing and then she was
accused of gay baiting at the time or
whatever and I'm not writing that off
I'm just saying like this is just just
to get through this story right and then
um
so so then she comes out and says hey I
you know I um
you know I apologize and this sucks and
then she blamed this kid Adam because he
wrote the tweet and he's a gay kid
himself
um and he wrote the tweet and he was
managing her social media so she threw
him under the bus through one of the bus
because she was having kids and she
chucked him under the [__] bus and
then like he felt alienated he had no
power he had no internet she had
approved that tweet should approve yeah
yeah she had to prove the Tweet multiple
times like four times I think Adam says
wow he has like you should just watch
this video really if you want to get
caught up on this I'm doing a truncation
of the whole thing he really goes
through the details of like screenshots
and all this stuff it's a laundry list
um you know as far as like he you know
the grooming accusation he's basically
saying like any time that
um Colleen wanted to talk to me it was
to get something out of me and to use me
for something so he feels like she
groomed him because
she would like manipulate him like Love
Like Love bomb him with compliments and
praise to get something out of him and
then she would ignore him and like she
would have him like drive because she
would do these tours and she would have
him like Drive he's like living in
Ireland so he's driving like for hours
with his parents oh my God and then she
would um say like let's meet up for
we'll have like a day we'll [__] hang
out and then like as he's driving for
hours with his parents she's like hey
like um why aren't you here yet I gotta
go like um I ordered you food like it's
gonna wait here or whatever and
basically he's saying like I was always
like it always seems like I was her
friend and then when it was time for us
to actually do friend things she would
bail on me so she used me groom me got
me to get information for her got me to
attack her ex-husband because they ended
up getting a divorce because Josh was
already feeling that way and then Josh
starts to hear that every that everyone
confirming that she was talking all
kinds of [__] on him right and that all
coalesced and they could they were
already having problems and it was over
and
so then um
and Josh is a very good dude by the way
I think he made some mistakes with the
you know being in those chats um just
and he's coughed all this stuff he's
like you know he feels bad that he
you know he was in a dark place and he
was like opening up about private things
to like a bunch of strangers but he felt
like a weird kinship with people I don't
know those are his words and then I mean
not exactly his words just trying to
summon it summon a lot
um
but yeah I think you know if anybody in
this
uh like I really don't have malice for
anybody here I just think that
you know if you're gonna do what she did
for a long time which is just like talk
all kinds of mad [__] about like a lot
of different things apparently she was
talking [__] on fans too
and like you know eventually it will you
know people will talk to each other and
go like yeah she did that yeah I was
there yeah even before all of this like
just from mutuals and just from I mean
tubers all talk right
I
already had in my mind that she was a
sociopath really yeah like from I forgot
like just it was once it was at um the
main place in Culver the YouTube space
some people were talking about it some
other man it was just
your bits and pieces throughout time and
I'm all like you know what's crazy it's
always these wholesome like they have a
kid audience or like something is like
you would never [__] expect them to
being like absolute sociopaths and like
people expect us to be these drug addict
[__] wild Cowboy ass rock stars and
in real life we're like the complete
opposites
yeah so I'm like to me I'm like dude
ever since I got into that space like
YouTube and just knowing these folks I
was just like [__] dude like it's crazy
and then I don't have any way to confirm
it but now everything's coming out and
it's like karma's a [__] let's go what
do you think of her apology video oh my
God what a [__] nightmare well first
of all so okay so her apology video she
gets a ukulele out and she sings a song
she sings the apology and deflects
doesn't address anything she just says
it's all lies and like like Wiggles her
way around it that guy Adam McIntyre is
he the only one that got groomed or he's
just one of the many one of many many
kids are coming out now saying the same
[__] many now adults are coming out
saying the same [__] but does she have
an audience still because I remember
back oh she's on tour right now I think
oh through and it's like mainstream
right yes really she was in um a Pixar
movie yeah Nick for a sec Netflix thing
too she had a Netflix show was it a
Pixar movie she was like for a minute I
think in um
Wreck-It Ralph 2 I think really she's in
one sec but yeah yeah that's a big deal
for a tuber that's a big [__] yeah
for sure and then um yeah she's done
very well for herself like I I was at
her house when she was with her husband
and they had a [__] killer house
pretty sure still lives there like it
was nice and it's in La so she's saying
an apology saying apology with a uke and
then accusation early YouTube but it
wasn't an apology it was like a defense
thing and the accusations are her
being using kids sexualized sexual with
kids being sexual kids is inappropriate
using kids to attack her ex-husband so
like she sent like little brigades to
like flood his Twitter account make him
feel real bad about himself I saw a lot
of that really yeah how often I mean how
recent is this that that it went down
this will hurt which part like her
[__] her going down is like right now
okay but what about her um that was five
years ago the divorce divorce was five
years ago yeah and then um The Grooming
of the kids has been going on since
apparently throughout the whole thing
yeah yeah and how was she grooming did
she have like is there accusations of
her having relationships with these kids
it's very not that it's more
manipulative it's not like sexual like I
I love dump you do all these things for
me I'm not your friend anymore and not
just that she would she'll tell him like
she told Anna McEntire she's like hey
like I'm thinking about turning into my
social media manager why don't you keep
working for me for free which apparently
he'd already be doing that sending her
ideas and all kinds of stuff he was just
excited he's she's a she's his favorite
person in the world and stuff like that
and then um so she she would um she's
like I'm considering you right now for
my social media intern
um
so I want you to take over my Twitter
account so that's when he posted that
thing and then she [__] blames him
also she has his friend who I think I
can speak for quite a few tubers that I
know he's one of the meanest people I've
ever met his name's Corey and uh oh
that's the other dude
it's one of the meanest [__]
I've ever met really and that's why
they're such good like friends I think
like they just have that same love
language of like let's just talk show
them everything like theater [__] yeah
yeah yeah yeah that kind of [__] so um I
don't think I'm speaking out of school
there I don't think that people are like
what a nice guy I think it's pretty
known
in the space because apparently they
would if a kid was out of line and
disagreeing with their [__] they would
use other kids to bully that kid so it
didn't look like they were doing it they
got an army of children yeah it is
[__] weird how old are they our age
they're like in their 40s and [__]
they're like uh she's our age 30s yeah
yeah definitely too old to be playing
with these kids like that yeah and
sending them underwear is weird right
but you know I get like the you know the
the people are like she took pictures
with kids where they're all holding up
tampons I'm like that I don't know dude
sometimes in the search to hunt someone
down you just take everything and go
that's evidence too and it's like that's
not really your point is it is that
really your point yeah like you can you
already made really good points you
don't have to like fire off every single
piece of Salvo that you're right right
that's the hard part about listening to
this coverage is people list a million
things because they're trying to like
surround you with like any way you look
it's bad the preponderance one of these
is bad yeah exactly that's it and it's
enough and in and it's fine but you
don't have to do all that [__] right
it's almost distracting from how bad it
is yeah and I honestly think too and I
no insult to um um Adam at all I really
do think that this thing was kind of
dying down actually like um as far as
like the amount of people who were
talking about it it was kind of on its
way of like you ever just milk a story
so [__] hard that there's no other
angles left to cover and it's over yeah
like like the [__] Titanic submarine
right yeah like with this story it was
over and then she did this ukulele video
and now it went viral but beyond
anything I've ever seen but she could
have just ended it I honestly think it
was it was like on death's door I don't
know that yeah but like I think it
seemed like I think a month from then
like nobody can really keep milk in that
[__] titty right so I think it was
pretty much on the way out and then when
she makes an apology like that it makes
her shut like it shows that she's really
out of touch and it becomes like not
just any apology it's like the most
parody topology video I've ever seen now
everyone's probably the worst example of
an of a response not even an apartment
and then uh is that when the uh and she
says it's all lies basically and then is
that when the kid came out and made a
video detailing with receipts after the
apology uh no before before she did the
ukulele video he is been turning up the
heat because somebody else kind of
brought all this back up to the surface
and then he gave really important
context clues about what the [__] was
going on the whole time from years ago
where he basically got run off the
internet by a bunch of of the Weenies
and Colleen fans because they basically
said he is now an Enemy of the State
sounds it sounds like he's saying every
time he says her name I'm like I'm sorry
it's colding though
she spells it like
close to me y-n-e yeah so when you heard
about all this none of it sounds
surprising to you I didn't even blink oh
well the only thing I blinked about was
the kid stuff because I had no idea
about the chat stuff I knew that she had
a fan base that was really um
um what do you call it like they loved
any rumor they could find of anything
okay yeah yeah dramas right and who
doesn't love the dramas but they were
like every little thing
blow it up into a big thing and then
like the truth is all the way over here
so like because I was inside of a lot of
that stuff as far as like just knowing
basic [__] about what was going on with
them and like they would be over here
like with wild [__] that doesn't make
any sense but then they almost have like
pieces of the truth yeah and they're
like running with it but it was too fun
over there yeah it's really fun it's
really yeah it's hard it was way more
[__] up though if I was a kid I'd done
the same [__] because it's fun to like
run with it but right but they were like
saying stuff like like clean those
Joshua anything in the world like I
don't know why like oh stuff like that
you're like right you're over here like
oh my
I'm like the [__] lady at the at the
casino with a cigarette I'm like oh
honey I'm just [__] here till I die
like the world is Bleak and dark you
have no idea so you've never known her
as anything other than like she's just a
general [__] no no so when I first
met her she was just normal the the fame
totally changed like she was normal and
nice and like probably like I really do
believe I think you believe this too
where you're probably the same person
and then you get power and then you show
us who you really are yeah but she was
very cool and I thought she was funny
and like yeah I don't know it's really
tough when you're going when you're when
you're looking at something like this
and people are just like like everyone
firing every arrow they have at her yeah
it gets tough because I know the more of
the full person can't say I've known her
for years now but the person that I knew
in the beginning I really did like her
like I didn't just hang out with her
because it was fun like it didn't do
anything for my YouTube career to hang
out with everybody we were just hanging
out with each other like she was just a
really cool person and
um and he and most importantly my buddy
Josh was really cool like a super good
dude honest with you
um he's like a southern thing because
he's from the south and [__] and my
mom's from the south so me and him got
on pretty quick and he's just a real guy
and then I was really disappointed to
see like how the fame changes people
it's happened a couple times I've been
in the tube space for a while I've seen
it happen quite a bit Yeah but it was
the way that they changed and became
like better than
um
yeah in that in that in that negative
space right where it's like you know
like a fan comes up and they're like
nervous or something and then the fan
leaves and they're like and she's like
doing a bit about it or whatever like
stuff like that is like right you know
where it's like I guess you know maybe
she's just relieving awkward tension and
just like trying to be like see I don't
think I'm that cool or whatever but it
was just weird right you're just like
this is weird and I can't say it's just
[__] on every fan she saw and like
that's kind of what's happening right
now unfortunately in this particular
story they're like she hated all of her
fans the truth is like this yeah yeah
sometimes like you really do meet an
awkward fan and then afterward you have
to joke about it to release the tension
oh yeah and don't you think like most
people always pin extremes
yeah like it's just like that's what
you're gonna run with regardless exactly
you're trying to like paint a narrative
it's like it's got to be the extremes
also in situations like this Everyone
likes to round up to the extreme of
course like this one's pure evil if you
could do this you could certainly do
this right but what do you think like so
with this out and with people finally
like kind of believing it what gets
taken away from her at all like at this
point honestly so I guess a bunch of you
know one sponsors sponsors have left and
stuff like that that's always like a
weird thing anyways because yeah we all
know that they're just there canceling
just doesn't work anymore yeah
um so what really happens is I think she
you know is gonna have that pit in her
stomach for a couple months and then um
you know eventually she'll just keep on
doing stuff because nothing actually she
didn't actually break the law in any way
huh I mean if her followers keep
following like what's the real
difference it's just people outside
coming in talking [__] but yeah but
people are doing this thing too where I
just think that the story has gone on
long enough where people are really
doing that thing of like law enforcement
do something YouTube do something like
and it's like that's not what this
actually is this is totally right this
is totally in the in the more in the
realm of like the public space and like
horror fans her fans yeah yeah because
like what is illegal about what she did
per site uh like per se I also think
that and I don't really want to beat up
on I don't think that this guy had a
McIntyre's parents are going to see this
but like your parents are really to
blame a lot that's true
like for as long as you did like talking
to a [__] adult at that age yeah and
and one of his things is he wants an
apology from Colleen and he and he wants
an apology to from Colleen to his
parents but it's like dude all the way
around parents are well she shouldn't
her parents shouldn't apologize to
Colleen but her parents should be
apologizing to Adam yeah his parents
should be opposing down because you're a
young kid everything that he's saying I
was 14. I was 14. yeah I did where are
your parents why aren't they trying to
get you off of this how are they not
monitoring how you communicate I mean
that's wild to me yeah it's pretty crazy
and I think that that's gone missing in
a lot of this too not to beat up on this
kid he's a really well spoken kid I
really do think that how does he know
but also with that approach that like
and how enamored he was with her he's
pretty lucky that it wasn't a more
predatory person yeah because like we
learned in the 90s because of Michael
Jackson honestly our parents were like
you see what happens you get too close
to someone you idolize this this could
happen that was that he Michael
Jackson's example so like we grew up
knowing
my my parents were like not your Mentor
do whatever the [__] he says
[Music]
thank you